اذا نتابع معكم مشاهدينا الكرام تغطيتنا
للحدث الابرز هذه الليله زلزلان جديدان
مركزهما وسط انطاكيا مركز ولايه هاتاي
جنوب تركيا وشعر بهما سكان سوريا ولبنان
وفلسطين والاردن وصولا الى مصر الزلزال
الاول بلغت شدته 6 درجات فاصل اربعه جنوب
تركيا بالقرب من الحدود السوريه اما
الزلزال الثاني فبلغت شدته خمسه درجات
فاصل ثماني على مقياس
الخسائر في تركيا حتى الان ثلاثه قتله
واكثر من 200 مصاب اما في سوريا فاعلن
المرصد السوري عن سقوط اربعه قتلى جراء
التدافع والهلع في حلب وطرطوس وقال صحفيون
ان 55 شخصا على الاقل القوا بانفسهم من
النوافذ خوفا من الزلزلين الاخيرين
نتابع في رصد الصوره من هاتايا التركيه مع
مراسل العربيه زيدان زنكلو زيدان ما الذي
تراه وتسمعه في هذه اللحظات
نعم طاهر في هذا المبنى الذي وصلناه قبل
قليل كانت فرق الانقاذ تحاول التاكد من
اشخاص موجودين تحت هذا المبنى الذي كان
بالاساس متصدع لكنه انهار بعد بشكل جزئي
بعد الزلزال الجديد لذلك الان بعد التاكد
من عدم وجود اي شخص تحت الانقاض بدات
السلطات او فرق الانقاذ احضرت هذه الجرافه
الضخمه وبدات بهدم المبنى بشكل كامل خشيه
انهياره
في حال كان هناك هزات ارتداديه كما نتابع
نحن هنا في منطقه دفنه طاهر هي هي مركز
الزلزال الجديد كما تتابعك وصلنا مع فرق
الانقاذ او وصلنا بعد وصول الفرق الانقاذ
الى هذا المبنى بدقائق قليله وتابعنا معهم
كل تفاصيل العمليه التي نشاهدها الان
بدايه من احضار الكلاب المدربه ومن ثم كان
هناك حريق تم اطفائه ايضا كانت حاولوا
ايضا التاكد موجود جثث او ما شابه تحت
الانقراض لكن عند التاكد مئه في المئه من
عدم وجود اي احد تم او صدر الامر بهدم هذا
المبنى منعا لانهياره في اي هزات ارتداديه
اخرى هنا في منطقه دفنه التي نتواجد فيها
في انطاكيا كما ذكرت طاهر يعني حتى الان
الحصيله
الاوليه لهذا الزلزال ونتمنى ان تكون
حاصله نهائيه هي ثلاثه قتله
ومئتان
وثلاثه عشر جريحا طبعا حاله من الهلع
والخوف الشديدين نتيجه الزلزال هنا في
في انطاكيا شاهدنا الكثير من السكان قد
احضروا بطانياتهم واتجهوا حتى ممن كان
يقيم في القيام حقيقه وفي القيام من ان لا
يكون هناك اي خوف من اي انهيارات لكن
الخوف والهلع حقيقه الحاله النفسيه السيئه
لدى الجميع نتيجه الظروف التي عاشها سكان
انطاكيا خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين شاهدنا الكثير من
الاشخاص يحملون بطانياتهم يشعرون النار في
الشارع ويجلسون لا يريدون العوده الى اي
مكان يريدون الشارع ايضا بعض شاهدناه في
السيارات
كان يفضل البقاء في السيارات وهي الحاله
التي تقريبا نفس السيناريو الذي عاشه
سفيان انطاكيا والولايات الجنوبيه في
الايام الاولى للزلزال الذي وقع في السادس
من فبراير الماضي يعني من خلال ايضا هناك
اجراءات احترازيه كثيره اجرتها السلطات
التركيه على سبيل المثال عند وقبل وصولنا
الى دفنه
كنا نريد ان نعبر من فوق جسر في نهر
العاصي او جسر فوق نهر العاصيه للمعلومه
فقط ان نهر العاصي يخترق مدينه الانفاكيا
وبالتالي هناك دستور للسيارات
عده جسور للسيارات لتقطع ما بين الضفتي
المدينه حاولنا ان نعبر لكن كانت الجيش
اخر اغلق بعض هذه الجسور خوفا من انهيارات
لم يتاكدوا ان كان هناك ضرر في هذه الجسور
لكن لا يريدون اي عواقب او اي اي احتمالات
لانهيارات لذلك تم اغلاق هذه الجسور او
بعض هذه الجسور الا لسيارات الاسعاف وفرق
الانقاذ لتعبر الى المناطق المتضرره طاهر
اليك بعد قليل لننتقل الى سوريا معنا من
سلقين في ادلب محمد
الاشقر الان يراسلنا من هناك محمد اهلا بك
الصوره الان من عندك
هو اذا كان بالامكان ان نرى الصوره خلفك
وفي محيطك وانت تتكلم لو سمحت
نعم يعني في الحقيقه نحن الان في مدينه
سلقين وتحديدا في شارع الكورنيش هنا حيث
تجمع اهالي المدينه والنازحون اليها بعد
الهزه الارضيه الجديده التي ضربت تركيا
وشعر بها معظم سكان شمال غرب سوريا طبعا
هنا في هذه في هذه المدينه انهارت بعض
المباني المتصدعه من الهزه الماضيه طبعا
هذه المباني كانت خاليه من السكان ولكن
هناك
الانهيارات باجزاء من بعض المنازل تسببت
باصابات طفيفه حيث قالت دفاع المدني
الاصابات
الغرب سوريا وصلت الى 130 اصابه معظمها
طفيفه اريد ان اشير هنا الى ان بعض
الاصابات كانت نتيجه رمي البعض انفسهم من
شروفات المنازل في الدوره المرتفعه هناك
البعض الذي اصيب نتيجه سقوط بعض الاحجار
عليه وهناك من اصيب نتيجه انهيار بعض
الجدران طبعا بالنسبه لمدينه انت سمحت لي
ان اتحدث قليلا عن مدينه جنديرس وهي
المدينه التي نالت التي تصدرت المشهد في
شمال غرب سوريا فان بحسب ما وصلنا من تلك
المدينه فقد انهار مبنيان بالاضافه لقبه
المدينه طبعا
الصوت يتقطع من لو تعيد المعلومات الاخيره
لو سمحت نعم
نعم كنت اتحدث عن مدينه جنديرس هذه
المدينه التي تصدرت المشهد الاعلامي نتيجه
النكبه التي تعرضت لها
طيب واضح ان الصوت يتقطع سنحاول اصلاح
الخلل مع محمد الاشقر مراسل العربيه من
سلقين في ادلب
كنا نشاهد يعني نرصد المشهدين التركي
والسوري في جانبي الصوره احدهما من ادلب
والاخر من هاتاي التركيه واعود اليها مع
زيدان مراسل العربيه من هناك مع التذكير
بما قاله وزير الزراعه التركي عن الاخطر
على السدود حاليا فيها بعد الزلزال جديد
مع تسجيل اثنتين وثلاثين هزار ارتداديه
جراء هذا زلزال وفقا لاداره الكوارث
التركيه
الاداء الرسمي مع هذه الماساه الجديده
زيدان يعني ما ابرز التحركات على الصعيد
الرسمي السياسي
الامني الطبي
الى ما هنالك
نعم يعني لحسن الحظ ان هذا الزلزال عندما
وقع كل الطواقم او فرق الطوارئ موجوده هنا
في المكان
طاهر لم تغادر المكان وهم كانوا يواصلون
العمل لذلك على بشكل سريع تم اغلاق الطرق
امام السيارات المدنيه ومحاوله افساح
الطريق لسيارات الاسعاف الفرق لانقاذ
للوصول الى الاماكن التي تم الابلاغ عن
وجود انهيارات فيها او شكوك بوجود
انهيارات فورا ايضا كان الحديث عن توجه
الطواقم الطبيه بشكل سريع حتى حتى لو لم
يكن هناك بلاغات يعني حقيقه مشاهدنا
السيارات الاسعاف تنتشر بشكل سريع في
المواقع التي وصلت بها بلاغات ايضا شاهدنا
سيارات اسعاف وصلت من خارج انطاكيا بسرعه
تم يعني عندما كنا عائدين الى انطاكيا
شاهدنا سياره اسعاف وصلت بسرعه او كانت
قادمه من خارج انطاكيا لدعم الجهود هنا
ودعم الطاقم الطبيه
على الفور كان هنا وزير الصحه وايضا وزير
الدفاع كانوا يشاركون ايضا كانوا في مركز
افاد مركز هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه
وزير الداخليه التركي وصل او توجه مباشره
الى هاتاي وبعد وصوله ادلى بتصريح كما
ذكرتم قال فيه ان ثلاثه اشخاص قد لقوا
حتفهم نتيجه هذا الزلزال يعني كما ذكرت
ايضا اتابع موضوع الهزات الابتداديه حتى
الان ولغايه الساعه
11:30 قبل حوالي 40 دقيقه كان عدد الهزات
الارتداديه
32 هز على امتداديه كان اكبرها 5.8 في
سمندار بحسب ما
ذكرت افاد انا احاول
مباشره ايضا بالنسبه لمطار هاتاي ايضا تم
تاكيد باعجم وجود اي اضرار في المطار لكن
كما تابعنا خلال الساعات الماضيه تم ايقاف
الطيران في المطار او تحويل الطيران الى
في المطار او الطائرات متقدمه الى المطار
الى مطار
الى مطار اخرى ولكن حتى الان او تم تاكيد
بشكل رسمي ان المطار بحاله جيده ولا يوجد
اي ضرر طبعا نحاول ايضا رصد كل الاخبار
التي تابعناها معكم
لمتابعتها بعد قليل لتوجيه الاسئله ولكن
اريد ان اتحول من جديد محمد عاده الينا
محمد الاشقر
طيب ربما نعود اليه في وقت لاحق لمدير
المرصد السوري رامي عبد الرحمن اهلا بك
استاذ رامي مره جديده ايضا كنت افدتنا
بسقوط اربعه قتلى في جراء التدافع والهلع
في حلب وطرطوس هذه الحصيله نهائيه بالنسبه
اليكم
الامر يعني
الارض ما الذي ما الحاله التي يعيشونها
حقيقه الامر يعني في كل هزه في تركيا يقول
هناك حاله رعب كبيره لدى من يشعرون بهذه
الهزه داخل الاراضي السوريه يعني الهزه
على الشريط الساحلي ومن يشعر بها في اقصى
شمال سوريا يخرج الى الشارع خوفا من ان
تنهار المنازل عن رؤوسهم ما بلك في الذين
انهارت المنازل على رؤوسهم او تصدعت
منازلهم لذلك اقول لك بان حاله رعب بشكل
كبير جدا الرعب هو يعني كلمه قليله على
الحاله التي يعيشونها هؤلاء السوريين
الموجودين في تلك المنطقه البعض من الشباب
قد يقول بان الامر عادي لا الامر ليس عادي
حتى الشباب يشعرون بالخوف يعني بمجرد
الاعزاء من لديه اسره الى الشارع ومن لديه
ليس لديه اسره يريد ان يهرا الى الشارع
يعني
ينقص حياتهم من الموت المحقق نتيجه النبوت
الذي شاهدوا
لكن زاد اعداد الناس الذين لا يستطيعون
العوده الى منازلهم بفعل التضرر من
الزلزلين الاخيرين الان
نعم بشكل قطعي لان هناك منازل
في الامر اصلحه الان المنازل جرى فيها
انهيار او انشقاق جديد ان هناك هناك من في
هذه المنازل لن يعود الى منزله ان هناك
الان في بانياس كما ذكرت في نشره سابقه
هناك في منازل كثيره اعتقدت بانها قويه
وايجابيه يعني يفهم الان في هذا تشققات في
جدران اي ان هناك خوف تمدد في المناطق
التي في الاساس لم يظلها الزلزال السابق
لان هذه الزلزال على ما يبدو ضرب الخط
الساحل اكثر من الداخل السوري والبدء
والمباني التي انهارت في حلال هي في
الاساس كانت متصدعه من السابق وايضا ذات
الشيء يا حمام طيب ما الذي يجب فعله الان
لو عمله للتخفيف عن الناس ما الذي ينقص
بان هناك استمرار استمرار
الاغراء المساعدات لابناء الشعب السوري
لنا من الذي ينقص ينقص الكثير حقيقه الامر
ينقص يعني نقوم بفعل شيء لا نستطيع مكبرين
حقيقه الامر
الذي يراها من بعيد او حتى غير الذي يتحدث
معهم يعيشون
تبقى معنا نحن نشاهد جوانب متعدده من
الصوره من ادلب من هاي في عده امكنه من
المطار من المدينه من صور اخرى من انطاكيا
ايضا صوره مباشره من
عدساتنا في هاتاي
للجرافه التي لا تزال تعمل على
بهدم المبنى المتضرر بعد التاكد من عدم
وجود من هو تحت الانقاض كما اذا افدنا قبل
قليل الصوره الرئيسيه من هاتاي محمد
الاشقر الان من ادلب سلقين تحديدا محمد
تنض مجددا اذا كان هناك لديك معلومات
جديده ويمكن ان تتابع ايضا بالمعلومات
التي كنت تدلو بها قبل انقطاع الاتصال عن
جنديرس
يعني كنت اتحدث عن غيار بناء متصدعين غير
بالسكان وماتنه مسجد في مدينه جنديرس
شماليه حلب في ريف طبعا هذه لا اصابات في
مدينه جنديرس وبحسب ما وصلنا من المدينه
فان الفرق
لازالت تتجول في احياء المدينه الى حد هذه
اللحظه للتاكد من عدم من للتاكد من عدم
انهيار اي مبنى جديد طبعا اما بالنسبه
لريف بحسب الدفاع المدني قال ان هناك تعدي
من المباني المتطبعه
انهارت في مناطق خربه الجوز والحمديه
والملاند والذوف وبيت طوفان في ريف ادلب
الغربي طبعا لا لا
لم ترد انباء عن وجود اصابات في هذه
المنطقه طبعا يعني بالنسبه لاعداد
المصابين نتيجه هذه الهزه الاخيره
الدفاع المدني ان عدد الاصابات هي 130
اصابه معظمها طفيفه طبعا
اتت الحالات بحالات ردود وكسور وحالات
اغماء وخوف هذا الزلزال طبعا هناك اصابات
نتيجه انهيار بعض الاشجار على بعض الاشخاص
هناك
اصابات نتيجه حاله الهلع حيث هناك العديد
من الاشخاص الذين رموا انفسهم من شروفات
المنازل يعني وبحسب مدني فان احصائيه
هي قبل للازبياء نهائيه حتى
طبعا ان سمحت لي ان الخص لك المشهد هنا في
مدينه سلقين باختصار لو سمحت نعم فقد
اجتمع الاهالي هنا
في اعداد هائله من ربما يعني اغلب سكان
المدينه والنازحين اليها نزلوا الى الشارع
على الاقل على الكورنيش نعم نعم
هنا على كورنيش تلقين لجاوا الى هذه
المنطقه خوفا من انهيار اي ابناء نتيجه
الهزات الارتباطيه ان حصلت في المستقبل
نعود اليك بعد قليل محمود شكر جاهز من
محمود المشهد من عندك نعم
المشهد من عندي نوعا ما يذهب الى الهدوء
بعد هذا الهلع والتوتر اجواء المدينه حتى
هذه الساعه لم يسجل فيها او لدينا اي
اضرار على المستوى البشري هنالك بعض
الاضطرابات وهي بطبيعه الحال جائزه
وتحديدا في البنايات المتشققه الجل الاكبر
من السكان المدينه لا يزالون في الخيام هم
خرجوا الى خارج الخيام عندما بدا الزلزال
منهم ما زال ينتظر في الشوارع او في
الساحات وفي الباحات الخارجيه الاستنفار
في جله كان في الذروه عند بدايه الزلزال
ان كان لاطقم الدفاع المدني او لاتقم
الكوارث او لاتقم الهلال الاحمر التركي او
ايضا للشرطه او للجيش الامور الان هدات في
المدينه وكما تشاهد نحن في قلب العاصمه
وامام المركز للولايه هنا في المساء كانت
تعج بمئات من الناس والسيارات وهيئات
للدفاع ول ايضا للهلال الاحمر الان هدات
نسبيا بانتظار الناس تتابع ان كان على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي او على التلفزه
ماذا يجري في المحافظات الاخرى لان
الزلزال هو ضرب
منطقه
هاتاي والارتدادات هي التي وصلت الى هنا
بالاضافه ايضا الى ان الكل يتخوف من ان
يكون هنالك من هزات اخرى لذلك هذا النوع
من التوتر المجبول بالخوف وايضا هذا الجو
الغير مستقر كنا بعد 15 يوما هنا في
المدينه طاهر نتحدث يعني ما بين الامس وما
بين اليوم عن الذهاب الناس الى بناياتهم
من اجل افراغ الاساس منها
والانتقال الى الم الاخرى نتحدث عن عمل
الجرافات اليوم على طول النهار
الساعه لرفع الارقاد نتحدث ايضا هنا في
المحافظه كانت الطوابير بالمئات للذين
يقبضون البدلات التي اقرتها الحكومه
التركيه ولا تصل الى عشره الاف ليره ولكن
الان مع المساء بدانا بملف اخر وهو الخوف
الى ان تاتي هزات اخرى وما لها من تداعيات
سلبيه ولها تداعيات بالبعد النفسي فضلا
على البعد ما ان كان يهدا الحال البنيوي
ما ان كاد يهدا حتى عادت التحالف اسوء حتى
عاد حال اسوا
شكرا على هذه الرساله حتى الان على الاقل
محمود شكر نعود اليك لاحقا معنا الصحفي
محمد جراد العبد الله من اسطنبول الان
اهلا بك كيف تتابع اسطنبول هذا المشهد في
المناطق المتضرره كيف تعيش هذه الليله مع
انباء الزلازل مجددا
يعني بشكل عام اسطنبول
مظاهر من القلق والهلع
الناس
اظن بانهم يتابعون عبر شاشات القنوات
التركيه او خلدو الى النوم
ولكن اسطنبول الكثير فيها الكثير من
الكلام فيها في الايام الاخيره منذ زلزال
سادس من فبراير عن امكانيه تعرضها هي
لزلزال قوي مع دعوات كثيره للكشف على
المباني ومنها من رئيس البلديه
بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو الذي وجه
النداء عاجلا الى السكان لاجراء الكشف
اللازم على قوه تحمل المباني
صحيح عمليات الكشف على المباني هي قائمه
منذ اكثر من عام
وخاصه في الاحياء القديمه مثل حي الفاتح
وتقريبا يعني لا يمر يوم الا وتشاهد وترصد
ابنيه تهدم
وتقام وتبدا عمليات انشاء جديده تراعي
الشروط اللازمه لمقاومه الزلازل الحديث عن
زلزال القادم في اسطنبول حقيقه خلق حاله
من القلق لدى سكان اسطنبول وهذا امر وارد
وكما تعرف اسطنبول تعرضت في يعني منذ عده
سنوات الى زلزال كبير في ضرب حي افجلار
واعيد بناؤه من جديد ولكن الان يتم
التركيز على الاحياء القديمه لا سيما حي
الفاتح حي الفاتح هو من اقدم الاحياء في
مدينه اسطنبول
ويجري فحص المباني وربما الان اخذ
عمليات فحص المباني تتسارع اكثر وايقاع
اشد من الماضي افرازال الذي
ضرب جنوب تركيا
اسطنبول مدينه مكتظه بالسكان رسميا عدد
سكانها نحو خمسه عشر مليون الى سته عشر
مليون هذه الاخبار او هذه التوقعات بان
اسطنبول تنتظر زلزالا مدمرا بلا اد خلق
حاله من القلق لدى سكان خاصه مع تحذير بعض
الخبراء من انه هكذا زلزال مدمر يمكن ان
يضرب اسطنبول قد تتراوح شدته ما بين
7.27.5 درجه خلال سنوات المقبله لا يمكن
التنبؤ بذلك بالضبط ولكن من المعروف بحسب
تقرير بلديه اسطنبول بانه يوجد فيها مليون
و46 الف مبنى واربعه فاصله خمسه مليون شقه
كل منها يضم 3.3 شخص في المتوسط وبالتالي
اذا وقع هكذا زلزال في المستقبل القريب او
البعيد ربما يعني التقديرات بانه الالاف
المؤلفه ستكون متضرره يعني بين قتيل وجريح
ومشرد بفعل تضرر هذه المباني خاصه هنا
نتحدث عن المبادئ التي لم يشرف عليها من
تلك التي بنيت قبل زلزال 99 اليس كذلك
نعم انا يعني
ركزت على حي الفاتح باعتبار باعتباره من
اقدم الاحياء في اسطنبول وهناك كثير من
المباني في هذا الحي التي هي ايل للسقوط
او يوجد تصدعات بها نتيجه عام 1999 لكن
ايقاع الكشف على على المباني في اللاسيمه
في الحياه القديمه اخذ يشتد في الاونه
الاخيره لاسيما بعد زلزال الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا اذا زلت تدارك بلديه اسطنبول
والسلطات في في تركيا
عمليات هزم المباني التي من الممكن ان في
في حال تعرض اسطنبول لاي زلزال لا سمح
الله يعني اذا
تداركت بلديه اسطنبول والسلطات التركيه
هذه المشكله الكبيره في مدينه مكتظه
حجم الخسائر كبيره جدا
ستكون كارثه كبيره جدا يبدو ان الناس يعني
مش يعني مش الكثير منهم مش الاغلبيه
العظمى هي التي فعل ذلك حتى الان على
الاقل يعني حتى طر امام اوغلولييت ليقول
للناس اتوجه الى سكان اسطنبول دعونا نفحص
هياكل للابنيه الخطيره لانها مساله حياه
يعني عاجله لا اكثر
وتنقل صحيفه شرق الاوسط هذا صحيح ولكن
السكان ليسوا هم المسؤولون عن هذه العمليه
يعني انا في البدايه في البناء الذي اعيش
به منذ حوالي سنه اتت خبراء او مهندسون من
بلديه اسطنبول واخذوا عينات من الاعمده
انذر سكان البنايه هو عمليه عباره عن مجمع
لكن القانون هنا اذا هناك ساكن واحد في
البنايه لا يوافق لا يتم هدم البناء اما
الان على ما يبدو سيتم اتخاذ اجراءات
جديده وقوانين جديده تلزم كل من يسكن في
بناء ممكن ان يتعرض للهدم او او يسقط في
حال وجود زلزال يبدو ان الامور ذهبه بهذا
الاتجاه لانه بالفعل
الدرس زلزال جنوب تركيا كانت درسا يعني
عميقا
للعموم ليس فقط لعموم تركيا وربما ربما
لعموم المنطقه بشكل بشكل عام انت ترى ان
الزلازل الاخيره وزلزال اليوم وزلزال سادس
من من هذا الشهر امتدا الى الدول المجاوره
التي تقع جنوب تركيا يعني هذا جعل من
السلطات
والناس يعني حذرين يعيشون حاله هلا يعني
اليوم بالصدفه كنت في مكان عام هنا في
اسطنبول احد الاشخاص كان في مدينه اضنه
اثناء يعني في سنه في السادس من الشهر
الحالي ويعني يروي لزملائي وانا اسمع
الحديث بانه الان لا زال يعيش في حاله هلع
بحيث ان اي شيء يتحرك يذكرهم الزلزال الذي
عايشه في مدينه انبا اضنه ضربت هذا مثالا
والتقيت وسمعت كثير من الروايات لمن عاشوا
الزلزال سواء في كهرمان مرعش او في
انطاكيا حقيقه الروايات
حاله الرعب التي
مازالا ما زال الناس يعيشونها او ما يسمى
بحاله الصدمه ما بعد بعد الكارثه التقيت
انا هنا في اسطنبول بعائلات مع اطفال
الاطفال هم اكثر من
تاثروا ويتاثرون
بهذه الكوارث طبعا نتحدث عن اطفال ناجين
وعلى ما يبدو تتجه الان
السلطات التركيه المعنيه
باخداع هؤلاء الاطفال لعمليات تاهيز
سيكولوجي لانه من من
الممكن ان تترك يعني تترك حاله الصدمه
اثارها على المدى البعيد هناك عائله سوريه
التقيت هنا في اسطنبول قبل يومين على
الاقل هم من اخبروني بان اطفالهم يعني
بحاجه لاعاده تاهيل سيكولوجي لانهم لا
زالوا يعانون من اثار الصدمه
بالعوده الى
يعني جيده انك تضرب لنا مثل هذه الامثله
واحد الامثله السابقه كان عن المكان الذي
تسكن فيه في اسطنبول ايضا وفق احصائيات
البلديه لم يطلب حتى الان اجراء المسح
الضوئي سوى من قبل 29 الفا من ملاك
الوحدات السكنيه من اصل 107 الف مبنى تم
انشاؤها قبل عام 99 اذا التوجه الان كما
فهمت منك لاجبار ملاك الوحدات السكنيه على
اجراء هذا المسح او على اجبارهم على
الموافقه على الهدم ان تطلب الامر ذلك
بالضبط يعني لن يترك لن تترك المساله
لخيارات الساكنين في المكان الحال قبل مثل
ما كان الحال حتى يعني حتى قبل زلزال
زلزال جنوب تركيا ويبدو ان هذه المساله
جدا ملحه ويبدو يعني حتى الناس انفسهم بعد
ما شاهدوه في بلدهم خلال الايام الاخيره
هم ايضا بداوا يبادرون
بابلاغ يعني السلطات المعنيه في البلديه
لاجراء عمليات المسح الضوئي التي كانوا
يرفضونها انا بتقديري عمليه الرف كانت
لانه عمليه اعاده هدم البناء واعاده بنائه
من جديد يتحمل الساكن جزء من من التكلفه
يعني تعطى
هنا بالضبط
هناك يعني مرافق للبناء الذي اسكن
بهدم والان تقريبا سيبداون بعمليات
الانشاء الجديده التي تتوفى يعني شروط
مقاومه الزلازل ستؤخذ بعين الاعتبار على
الاقل في منطقه الفاتح مؤخرا في الاشهر
الاخيره بدات بدات تشاهد وبشكل ملحوظ هدم
ابنيه
واعاده بناءها من جديد لكن
باعتقاده ان ان الساكنين هنا يعزفون عن او
لا يوافقون حتى الان تقريبا على هدم
الابنيه التي يسكنون بها لانهم سيتحملون
جزءا لا باس لا باس به من عمليات اعاده
بناء هذه الشقاق لكن اظن الان بعد الكارثه
التي حلت بتركيا ان ان
الساكنين هذه هذه الابنيه لاسيما في
الاحياء القديمه هم يبادرون
ايضا عند السلطات اقناع هؤلاء الناس
بالمغادره او بالهدم لانه في مجمعات كانت
تعتبر فاخره تم بناؤها حديثا وقبل بضع
سنوات فقط ومش قديمه
صحيح
وكانت مقاومه للزلازل
يعني انا اللي انا بحكي عنه ما قيل عن
هاتاي وهو مجمع رامي اللي كان يسكنوا مئات
الاشخاص ونهار تماما وكان يروج على انه
مقاوم للزلازل
نعم يعني ربما ربما كانوا يقولون قوم
للزلازل ولكن نتيجه انه لم يعني لم يقاوم
هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
يعني الروايه الاكثر ترجيحا ان اثناء
عمليه البناء او اثناء عمليه البولتيه ما
هذه المجمعات الجديده يعني لم تؤخذ شروط
مقاومه الزلازل بعين الاعتبار بمعنى اخر
ان هناك غش في في عمليه بناء تتعلق بنقص
الاسمنت او التسريع الى ما هنالك هل اتخذت
الاجراءات الضروريه اللازمه القانونيه
والامنيه وعلى مختلف الاصعده في هذا
الاطار او لا يزال عمل قائما على ذلك وهل
السلطات قادره على محاصره الجميع كل
المتورطين مهما اختلفت مستوياتهم
الى الان يعني نحن نتابع عبر الاخبار ان
هناك عدد يعني تجاوز الثلاثين
مقاول تم توقيفهم وحدهم صاحب هذا المجمع
المتعهد الذي بنى المجمع في انطاكيا
المجمع الفاخر والذي تسكنه النخب
في في انطاكيا جرى توقيفه هنا في مطار
اسطنبول وكان على امه المغادره الى
جمهوريه الجبل الاسود يعني الان لا نستطيع
يعني الى الان لا نستطيع ان نؤكد بان هناك
عمليات غش ارتكبها هؤلاء المقاولون ادت
الى هذا الى ازدياد عدد الضحايا هو انه
خرجت دراسات مقارنه مع دول اخرى
تراعي موضوع شروط
البناء لمقاومه الزلازل فكان عدد الضحايا
اقل ولو كان في منطقه يعني في في في منطقه
هاتاي او بكهرمان مرعش اخذت هذه المسائل
بعين الاعتبار
من المؤكد لكان عدد الضحايا اقل بكثير هذه
هذا ما تقوله الدراسات طبعا واظن بان هذه
الدراسات علميه بعد قليل
استاذ محمد اعود الى محمد الاشقر الان من
سلقين في ادلب
مراسل العربيه محمد ما ابرز يعني
يقوله الناس الان وحيث انت
لجهه خياراتهم ما بعد هذه الايام العصيبه
الخيارات اقل بكثير في داخل السوري
الخوف سيبقى قائما ربما لمده غير محدده لا
علميا ولا بشكل غير علمي فبالتالي ما هي
خياراتهم ما الذي سيلجاون اليه مع الحاله
التي وصلت اليها حاله الخوف وحاله المنازل
نعم يعني في الحقيقه حاله زعر يعيشها اغلب
سكان منطقه شمال غرب سوريا ودعني اتحدث
بالتحديد عن الناس الذين اشاهدهم هنا في
مدينه سلقين
نالت نصيبها من الدمار واعداد الضحايا
نتيجه الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
اغلب الاهالي الذين يتجمعون الان في
كورنيش مدينه سلقين هم شاهدوا وعاشوا
اللحظات الاولى للكارثه هذا الامر دفع
الاغلبيه منهم بان يعني يتفاعلوا مع اي
عزه ارتداديه يشعر بها
ويسرع باتجاه الشوارع حفاظا على انفسهم
وعلى عائلاتهم وعلى اطفالهم خصوصا ان حاله
الرعب تنتشر بين الاطفال اغلب الاطفال
باتوا يرون في الخيمه ملاذا امنا اكثر من
المنزل طبعا دعني اشير الى نقطه مهمه هناك
بعض العائلات التي
رفضت ترك منازلها مع انها مع ان منازلها
مهدده بالسقوط متصدعه نتيجه الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب المنطقه ولكن نتيجه عدم
وجود ماوى يؤويهم دفعهم للبقاء في منازلهم
طبعا يعني
هناك بعض
المنازل التي زادت
تصدعاتها نتيجه هذه الهزه القويه التي
حدثت الليله هناك بعض الشروحات التي نهارت
هناك بعض جدران المنازل التي انهارت هناك
بشكل كامل كانت متصدعه من قبل هنا اتحدث
عن عن
منازل في بعض القرى والبلدات في ريف ادلب
الغربي في هذه القرى المحاذيه لريف
اللاذقيه وهنا اتحدث عن قرى خربه الجوز
وبيت صوفان والملاند والحمزيه طبعا
انهيار طبعين في مدينه جنديرس طبعا
بعمليات الكشف والمراقبه
والهدم ان تطلب الامر او الاصلاح
محمد
يبدو فقدنا الاتصال مع محمد الاشقر مراسل
العربيه من سلقين في ادلب جمعه كاش من
القامشلي مراسل العربيه اهلا بك ماذا نعرف
مساء الخير والساده المشاهدين طبعا وفق
احداث المعلومات هناك طفله توفت في طرطوس
بسبب توقف في القلب بسبب حاله الهلع
والرعب التي اصابت الطفله واهلها حتى الان
ايضا هناك حوالي 200 اصابه مختلفه
طاهر بسبب يعني اغلبها بسبب يعني الخوف
والهلع
يعني حالات التازم في القلب من هذه
الحالات 130 في ارياف حلب وادلب فقط
المباني المتضرره طاهر تقريبا سبع سبع
مباني انهارت بشكل كامل هناك مباني اخرى
يعني هناك انهيار جزئي فقدت اجزاء من
الجدران او من الواجهات خاصه الواجهات
الملبسه بالحجر الطبيعي واضافه الى تضرر
العشرات من المباني الاخرى لحسن الحظ معظم
هذه
يعني الى اي مدى يمكن ان نقول انها ساعدت
في ما حصل الليله
طاهر يعني حتى الان التداعيات لا تزال
قائمه الاف من الناس خاصه في مناطق النظام
لا تزال في مراكز
المؤقته هناك اكثر من 200 مركز ومؤقت
اغلبها مدارس خاصه في اللاذقيه وحلب ايضا
هناك حتى هذه اللحظات يعني عائلات منذ
زلزال الاول وحتى الان كانت تسكن في
الحدائق العامه وتحت الجسور في شوارع
الكبيره لم تحصل حتى على خيمه وبالتالي
جاء هذا الزلزال ليفاقم معاناه
يعني الناس القائمين في مراكز الايواء
المؤقته اضافه الى ذلك هناك الان الالاف
من السكان الذين خرجوا من المنازل باتجاه
اما مراكز لواء مؤقته او الارياف وهذا
يشكل الان ضغط اضافي على على هؤلاء
المنكوبين اصلا في زلزلين الاولين
وبالتالي هذا يؤكد ضروره استمرار ايصال
المساعدات عبر كل الطرق والوسائل المتاحه
لكل الاطراف المتضرره
بالضبط يعني هذا
يفاقم الازمه الانسانيه القائمه وايضا
الازمه في القطاع في القطاع الطبي ويشكل
ضغط اضافي على يعني
المانحين او حتى على الامم المتحده او
الجهات التي قدمت مساعدات للمنكوبين نحن
الان نتحدث عن يعني اعداد اضافيه ستنضم
الى الاعداد القائمه فعليا والتي تحتاج
الى مساعدات مستدامه وليست مساعدات متقطعه
لان المشكله لا تزال قائمه
واحتواء التداعيات لم يحصل على مستوى كبير
واستمرت الحاجه الى المساعدات سواء كانت
انسانيه او اغاثيه او حتى طبيه وبالتالي
هذا الزلزال سياقم المشاكل التي لا تزال
قائمه حتى الان
تبقى معنا غنويتين من بيروت اهلا بك كيف
هو الوضع الان
هذه المره شعروا فيها اكثر من المرات
السابقه كنا قد شاهدنا مواطنين خرجوا من
منازلهم ومن ابنيه خاصه من الابنيه
القديمه ان كان في بيروت او في مناطق اخرى
في لبنان وخاصه في الشمال في طرابلس
يعني بعض المواطنين يقولون انهم يرفضون
يعني العوده الى المنازل حتى ان بعض
البلديات امنت
اماكن في العراء اذا فضل المواطنون البقاء
البقاء فيها ايضا كان هناك قرار صدر من
وزاره التربيه بتعليق الدراسه يوم غد في
المدارس وفي الجامعات وطالبو ادارات
المدارس باجراء فحص
للابنيه لابنيه المدارس
للتاكد من سلامه البناء كي لا يحدث اي شيء
يضر الطلاب
ايضا منذ السادس من فبراير زلزال الكبير
مع المباني مع الابنيه خاصه القديمه
يعني المتضر عبر تقادم هل حصل ذلك حتى
الان
يعني عندما
كان هناك تصدعات في بعض الابنيه خاصه
الاغنياء هي اللي اصلا يعني هناك شكوك حول
سلامتها وكانوا قد طلبوا البلديه والجهات
المعنيه بالكشف عليها ولكن يبدو انه يعني
لم يكن هناك
تجاوب مع هذه الطلبات حتى اليوم بعد سكان
النبعه وصلوني قالوا لنا بانهم طالبوا
البلديه باجراء كشوفات على امنياتهم
القديمه وهذا ما لم يحصل
تخوف ليس فقط من قوه الزلزال هناك تخوف
لان هناك ابنيه قديمه من ان يكون هناك حتى
ان كانت هزه خفيفه مع كثره الهزات التي
تحصل بان يحدث شيء غير متوقع ولكن بالنسبه
لي قوه
الجلاله او الهزات يعني جميع الخبراء في
لبنان
الجيولوجيين يعني يحاولون طمانه المواطنين
بانه لا يوجد ما يثير الرعب مركز بحمس كما
قد اصدر
في ساعات متاخره من الليل بيان تحدث فيه
بان الهزه التي حدث فيها التي شعر فيها
اللبنانيون اليوم كانت
هزه ارتداديه لما حصلت في تركيا وايضا بان
هناك لا يوجد تمدد لموجات تسونامي لانه
ايضا سرت شائعات من صيام وامس بان هناك
تراجع لمياه البحر والبعض تحدث عن ان هناك
تسونامي قد يضرب لبنان وهذا كله يعني
يثير يسير في الكثير من الاشاعات في
الحقيقه في هذه الايام والاخبار المغلوطه
او غير الدقيقه حتى يعني
كبار اساتذه الجيولوجيا في الجامعات
الاجنبيه في لبنان مثل الدكتور طوني نمر
من الجامعه الامريكيه كان كتب ليلى على
تويتر بانه عائلته في المنزل وانه سيلتحق
بهم من مكتبه بعد قليل وغدا سارسل اولادي
الى المدرسه اعتقد ذلك كان قبل قرار وزاره
التربيه والتعليم باغلاق او تعليق الدراسه
غدا ولكن كان يحاول ان يطمئن الناس مثل ما
قلتي اضافه الى عديد الاخبار المطمئنه
الاخرى وسط حاله
هلع اذا افهم منك اكثر بس المزيد من
التركيز والتدقيق على هذه النقطه في في
بيروت تحديدا او او في مناطق ساحليه اخرى
ايضا او
المناطق يعني لا يزال ناس في الشوارع هل
قرروا ان يبيتوا ليلتهم في الشارع
بدون ان يعودوا الى بيوتهم
لم يتخذوا بعض قرار العوده لانه كما يعني
نحن حتى سالنا يعني سالنا المواطنين لماذا
توجهتم الى الشارع لانه بحسب الخبراء اذا
مرت الهزه ولم يحدث شيء لكم هذا يعني انكم
في مامن لكنه يعني هناك حاله من الرعب
يعني خاصه بعد المشاهد التي شاهدوها في
تركيا
اخرى تكون قويه تؤثر على المباني خاصه وان
هذه الهزات لم تتوقف منذ الزلزال الاول
يعني حتى يوم الخميس
شاهدنا هزتين في نفس الوقت واحده في نفس
اليوم واحده صباحا وواحده مساء وهذا امر
لم يعتده اللبنانيون رغم ان خبراء
الجيولوجيا يقولون ان لبنان عاده يشهد
الكثير من الهزات التي ربما لا يشعر بها
المواطنون يعني موضوعنا ذات ربما يكون
طبيعي ربما على
قوه اقل من التي يشعرون بها الان ولكن
الشعور المواطنين بها مع كل الاخبار التي
يشاهدونها من الخارج هذا الامر يثير الخوف
لديهم خطا وانه في عوامل عديده على مختلف
الاصعده قد لا تساعد في في لبنان اذا حصل
اي مكروه لا سمح الله فيما يتعلق بهذا
الوضع ربما الوضع مختلف في دول اخرى مع
الوضع الاقتصادي
والسياسي المعروف في لبنان في الفتره
الاخيره
يعني انا ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر شكرا
جزيلا لك من بيروت مراسله العربيه غنوه
يتيم اعود الى محمد جراد العبد الله صحفي
من اسطنبول وابحث معك في نقطه
البعد السياسي لما يحصل الى اي مدى وفق
متابعتك لسياسه الداخليه في تركيا يمكن ان
يكون ذلك مؤثرا بشكل سلبي على اداء حزب
العداله والتنميه وعلى اجراء الانتخابات
ككل في
ايار مايو المقبل كما اراد اردوغان ان
يقربها او في يونيو كما هو مقرر سلفا
بانه بلا شك متاكد
بان
الارتدادات السياسيه ستكون كبيره
للزلازل التي ضربت وما زالت تضرب جنوب
تركيا بالتاكيد المعارضه ستستغل هذا الحدث
وهي تراقب وتحاول ان تمسك الناس
واداء السلطه السلطه التنفيذيه هذا اكيد
وبدات الانتقادات وشاهدنا يعني قبل عده
ايام كيف رد الرئيس التركي بغضب على احد
اهم المنافسين والذي كان في يوم من الايام
هو من حزب العداله والتنميه اقصد هنا علي
بابا
يعني كانت تدل على انه يعني غاضب من
تصريحات هذه الشخصيه السياسيه من حيث
المبدا ستكون ارتدادات الزلازل السياسيه
على المشهد الانتخابي ستكون كبيره هذا بلا
اي شكل ولهذا نجد الان هذا النشاط المحموم
السياسيين او الحزب العداله والتنميه لكي
لا يتركوا اي ثغره يمكن ان تستغلها
المعارضه في موضوع الانتخابات
التقديم الانتخابات على ما يبدو يعني صبر
به قرار او او صوت عليه البرلمان ولكن
امام هذا التطور المفاجئ ليس مستبعدا ان
تعود ان تعود ان تعود السلطه التنفيذيه
وتؤجل الانتخاباته حتى ربما لما بعد شهر
حزيران
الوضع يعني تحت تحت المجهر من طرفي
المعادله السياسيه هنا في تركيا يعني
الاصوات التي تذهب الى انه لا يمكن
تشريعيا وقانونيا ان تؤجل الانتخابات اكثر
من ذلك ولكن عموما يعني الكثير مما يمكن
ان يؤثر
على يعني الكثير من التطورات التي يمكن ان
تجبر الاتراك على فعل ذلك عاجلا ام عاجلا
ارجو ان تبقى معنا اذهب الى زيدان زنكلو
مجددا منها هل من جديد
نعم طاهر كما تتابع اعمال فرق الانقاذ
تواصل اعمال رفع الانقاض في الياباني التي
دمرت نتيجه الزلزال الجديد هنا في انطاكيا
وتحديدا نحن في منطقه دفنه مركز الزلزال
الجديد في انطاكيا حصيله القتلى حتى الان
ثلاثه قتله
جميعهم هنا في هاتاي اثنان في مركز
انطاكيا الاول هنا في منطقه دفنه والاخر
في مركز مدينه انطاكيا الشخص الثالث الذي
قتل كان في سمندق القريبه من انطاكيا حيث
كان هناك هزه ارتداديه بقوه
5.8 على مقياس ريختر كانت هذه الهزه
الارتداديه بعد ثلاث دقائق من وقوع
الزلزال الاول الذي كان في تمام الساعه
الثامنه واربع دقائق بالتوقيت المحلي في
تركيا نتابع فرق الانقاذ وهي تواصل العمل
بحسب ما علمناه ان حسب ما صرحت به طبعا
الحكومه التركيه ان
المطار هاتاي لا يوجد فيه اي اضرار اضافه
الى ان وضع السدود جيد لا يوجد اي مشكله
في السدود في هاتاي هناك تشققات في بعض
الطرق
جديده التشققات جديده في بعض الطرق في
انطاكيا نتيجه الزلزال الجديد طبعا بحسب
ما نعلمه الان
هزه ارتداديه اخرى هزرت جديده على ما يبدو
نعم شعرنا بها لكن خفيفه نعم
بحسب ما مراسلنا في
الهواء مباشره هزه ارتداديه جديده في
اثناء تغطيته
للزلزالين اللذين حصل هذه الليله في
هاتاي حيث يغطي
تفاصيل عمليات هدم بعض المباني التي كانت
ايله للسقوط او متضرره بالكامل وبعد ان
ثبت انه ليس تحتها يعني اي
مواطنين عالقين اذن هزار ارتداديه خفيفه
في تركيا ضمن سلسله الهزات الارتداديه
الكثيره التي حصلت منذ هذا الزلزلين ومنذ
زلزال الكبير في السادس من فبراير بطبيعه
واثرت على عدد من دول المنطقه انتقل بك
الى الشق السياسي الان زيدان لو سمحت ولو
انت على الارض في الميدان ولكن تتابع عن
كثب واول باول يوميا تفاصيل
يعني
ما تقول به المعارضه وكيف ترد الحكومه او
نظام ككل على هذه في البدايه كان هناك
اجماع على الحاله الانسانيه ثم سمعنا بعض
الاصوات التي
تستغل الموضوع سياسيا كما تتهمها الحكومه
او حزب العداله والتنميه على الاقل بابرص
قياداته
كيف هو يعني الوضع الان وبناء على معطيات
الايام السابقه وما يمكن ان يتطور اليه
الوضع السياسيا من تراشق اعلامي وسياسي
بعد ما حصل
نعم لا شك ان تداعيات الزلزال على المشهد
السياسي ستكون كبيره جدا بدات التداعيات
بشكل طفيف
تصريحات من هنا وهناك تحديدا انتقادات من
المعارضه التركيه للاجراءات الحكوميه منها
على سبيل المثال للحصر عدم تدخل الجيش في
يشكل مباشر في الايام الاولى هي عمليات
البحث والانقاذ
وان هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه هي من
كانت تقود هذه العمليه ايضا من الانتقادات
التي قراتها سمعتها من
زعيم المعارضه التركي كمالك الجدار اوغلو
انتقادي نقد وجهها للحكومه التركيه لايقاف
عمليه التعليم بشكل مباشر في الجامعات
والانتقال الى التعليم عن بعد ايضا كان
هناك انتقاد لتاخر وصول الاليات
والمساعدات للمناطق المنكوبه طبعا من ضمن
ايضا اضافه للانتقادات كان هناك
مختلفه من قبل قاده المعارضه
وتاكيدهم على رفض اي تاجيل للانتخابات
القادمه الحكومه التركيه وتحديدا حزب
العداله والتنميه وحزب الحركه القوميه لم
يصرحها بشكل رسمي حتى الان عن هذا الموضوع
لكن
اتحدث هنا مثلا عن بولانت ارينتش وهو احد
كبار مؤسسي حزب العداله والتنميه وهو الان
قيادي سابق في الحزب لم يعد موجود في
الحزب كان ان نشر تقريرا او تصريحا في
احدى وسائل الاعلام التركيه قبل ايام دعا
فيه الى تاجيل الانتخابات لكن تقارير
صحفيه مقربه من الحكومه
حتى الان تشير الى ان الانتخابات ما تزال
في موعدها وهذا بطبيعه الحال تحدي كبير
امامه حزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بسبب الزلزال وهذه
الاحداث الغير متوقعه
والماساويه التي تشهدها ولايات الجنوب
التركي في محاوله طبعا
لسحب البساط من يد المعارضه والانتقادات
لذلك نراها بشكل دائم في زيارات الى
المناطق المنكوبه طبعا الوزراء كل وزراء
الحكومه التركيه منذ وقوع الزلزال وحتى
اليوم لم يغادروا هذه المناطق كل وزير في
ولايه يتابع مع فرق الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه اخر عمليات البحث والانقاذ ويتابع
اولا باول ويزور المناطق المتضرره الحكومه
تحاول قدر الامكان وتحديدا المسؤولين
الحكوميين ومسؤولين حزب العداله والتنميه
التواجد على الارض ومع الناس وفي المخيمات
لاعطاء صوره ايجابيه ومحاوله امتصاص الغضب
في بعض المناطق وبعض الحالات بسبب
المحاولات بعض المواطنين هل اتت اكلها
واذا كان هناك ايه نسب او ارقام او
احصاءات
للواقع السياسي بين مؤيد ومعارض في الفتره
الاخيره ما بعد زلزال سادس من فبراير
عشيره الانتخابات يعني المفترضه او
المجمعه اذا تغيرت الارقام او ظل كل يعني
شيء على حاله لجهه الانتماءات
لا شك الان يعني نتحدث هنا نقطه مهمه نريد
الحديث عنها كثير من المناطق التي ضربها
الزلزال هي مناطق
لحزب العداله والتنميه نتحدث عن ولايات
غازي عنتاب ايضا بعض المناطق حتى هنا في
هاتاي مثلا منطقه ريهانلي او بقيه المناطق
القريبه من الحدود السوريه المتاخره من
الحدود السوريه و كهرمان مرعش كل هذه
المناطق هي قواعد انتخابيه لحزب العداله
والتنميه لكن هناك مشكله برزت خلال الايام
الماضيه وهي مشكله المقاولين والحديث عن
عدم استيفاء المباني التي دمرت للشروط
الشروط الموضوعه من قبل الحكومه الخاصه
بالزلازل لذلك تحركت الحكومه فورا
وقامت باعتقال عشرات المقاولين الذين
كانوا مسؤولين عن هذه المباني حتى الان
المشهد السياسي لا يمكن قياس نجاح الحكومه
او او رضا الشارع بشكل عام حتى نكون
دقيقين في الشارع عن الاداء الحكومي ربما
يحتاج الوقت او يحتاج الموضوع الى بعض
الوقت ربما الاسابيع القادمه قد تكشف لنا
مدى رضا الشارع وتحديدا مراكز الدراسات
واستطلاعات الراي هي من ستعطينا النتائج
فيما كان المواطن التركي او الشارع التركي
راضيا عن الاداء الحكومي خلال فتره
الكارثه ام لا
مراسل العربيه من هاطاي ونحن لا زلنا
نتابع صور محاولات يعني هدم احد المباني
وهذه صور حديثه الان تصلنا لسيارات اسعاف
امام احد المباني المتضرره بشده من هذا
الزلزال مع رفع احد السلالم لمحاوله انقاذ
بعض الناس عدد كبير من السلطات
الامنيه من عناصر الاسعاف
والدفاع المدني من جميع ومختلف القطاعات
والمؤسسات المعنيه بان تكون متواجده في
مثل مسرح العمليات هذا مع المباني
المهدمه او المتضرره بشكل كبير اذا موجوده
امام بعض هذه المباني التي نرى كيف تاثرت
وتضررت وتصدعت وتهدم جزء منها على الاقل
بفعل هذين الزلزلين الاخيرين وهما اللذان
نتج عنهما حتى الان مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص
واصابه 213
شخصا جراء الزلزال الجديد وفقا لوزير
داخليه تركيا اخر الانباء ايضا افادتنا
وفقا للمرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
بمقتل اربعه اشخاص في حلب وطرطوس وحماه
جراء التدافع
والهلع كنا رصدنا خلال هذه الساعه ايضا
تجمعات الاهالي في عدد من المناطق السوريه
واللبنانيه في سلقين بسوريا بادلب تحديدا
خوفا من الهزات الارتداديه في بيروت ايضا
مع غنوه يتيم مع محمود شكر ايضا تابعنا
الموضوع من اديمان مع جمعه عكاش من
القامشلي يعني بقيه ضيوفنا الصحفي محمد
جراد العبد الله من اسطنبول وقد نا معه
احتمالات يعني حصول
زلزال في اسطنبول وتحضيرات او مخاوف الناس
والسلطات هناك من ذلك من خلال الكشف على
المباني
المتصدعه او متضرره عبر التقادم خاصه التي
بنيت قبل زلزال 99 الذي اودى انذاك بحياه
الالاف من الاتراك نحن نتحدث هنا عن سبعه
عشر الفن مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه
للزلزالين الجديدين في تركيا وسوريا
وهما اللذان شعر بهما ايضا سكان ومواطنوا
دول عديده في تلك المنطقه ولكن مع ابراهيم
بدر بعد قليل ارجو ان تكونوا معه ابراهيم
مرحبا بك نعم